yeah plenty of tents these are the best
seats in the House for tomorrow's
possession as you say and some people
here have actually been camping out for
days to bag their spot here to witness
the historic moment there are flags
everywhere as you can probably imagine a
few banners I'm told there are some
inflatable corgis bobbing around
somewhere I'm yet to find them there's
even if you look over there a cardboard
cutout of the late Queen apparently uh
her son King Charles is somewhere here
too and over here
we have Cara from Kent he's been camping
out since oh excuse me since month I
thought you arrived Monday no Tuesday
okay well still a long time tell us why
um because I just love the royal family
you know since uh a little child my man
used to buy all the magazines and tell
me about all the royal family because
she actually worked there oh really wow
and this isn't the first time you've
camped out for a royal occasion is it
the sixth time
so the first one was what like Lila and
then it was uh the children Prince
William and Harry's wedding
and then I went to the queen mother's
funeral then I went to the Queen's
funeral and now I'm going to the Kings
Donnie wow I mean some people might say
you're mad to do it so what what why and
what's it been like so many days out
here sleeping in in a town I've got
loads of friends that I've met from
previous
um events and yeah we've just all
all look after one another you know get
used to speaking to other people that
are new here there's a real sense of
camaraderie isn't there yeah well thank
you very much Cara enjoy the day and I
think we just got time to speak uh to
Nigel and Vicky over here who are
sitting down here
and if you just tilt the camera down
we'll see they're they're busy bags they
haven't got a tent they're sleeping
essentially a glorified plastic bag
what's it like
it's been fine last night yeah fantastic
I mean the weather wasn't too bad to
that much rain not chilly no no no too
bad it's quite warm in a you know baby
bag we had a mattress to sleep on so it
was fine wouldn't it yeah yeah what are
you most looking forward to tomorrow
just very quickly oh all of it
start to finish yeah yeah
all of it every Everything the pump and
ceremony We Do It Best don't we in
Britain um let's go and chat to a group
here have been here since Tuesday this
group of women
hello there Shirley let's come to you
first um you've been here since Tuesday
what's it been like why do you do it we
do it because it's fun and people you
know and People You Meet
um and because of the the
um royalty
it's just it's something we really need
is the monarchy
it benefits the country and we just love
supporting them and it's good fun cold
yes well thank you let's move along the
line Margaret um uh how cold has it been
I mean it's okay now but I think at
night time it probably does get quite
chilly it was very cold the first night
because we had the um wonderful full
dress rehearsal
which went on until after three in the
morning not complaining it was magic but
by then noisy yes but we were up
watching it so by 3 30 we got very cold
and by the time we got into our sleeping
bags you couldn't warm up so we only
managed probably an hour and a half that
night
but since then we've been warmest toast
and how do you keep morale up these are
the the kind of shelters you're staying
in behind covered in tarpaulin and I'm
assuming you've got a lot of Provisions
you're sipping tea here already oh yes
how are you keeping morale high it's
easy with this crowd great crowd of
friends we're like a lot of giggling
girls half the time we have a good stock
of Brandy to go in the hot chocolate
and various other things things like
that they do help to oil the works I'm
sure they do well thank you very much
for sharing that with us that sharing
that little tip I'm sure will be a great
time tomorrow not long to go now and I'm
sure for all these people it'll be well
worth the wait